up to now we've been playing a lot of
chords
but you know all great music comes from
scales
and scales would be a good place to
start right now when we think of scales
we think in terms of numbers and letters
numbers being the fingers of the left
hand one two three
four
the scale we'll play is
i get elizabeth now to show you the
fingering we will use
three
one
open three one open two open three two
open three you show off
that was great
and the letters of course are the names
of the notes we play like
g
a low g a c
an a and so now show us uh the scale
that we just played well
g
f
e
[Music]
great well
we're going to do a couple of new chords
that you don't know yet probably
an a minor we will do show them a chord
there elizabeth
all right
an a minor
[Music]
and then a d minor
isn't that beautiful
[Music]
okay here's the scale tune
one two three four
do
[Music]
john denver's country rhodes is one of
america's favorite songs we're going to
show you how to play it now along with a
couple of new chords
e minor is the first one we will show
you
nice little chord requires only two
fingers
[Music]
and we'll use an f chord in the song
also
[Music]
there'll be some fancy right hand work
in this tune too and i'll show you how
we do that in slow motion
one
two three and four and one
and so on remember this may be difficult
for you at first but once you practice
and practice and learn something it
becomes easy and a lot of fun let's try
country roads
one two one two three four
[Music]
do
um
[Music]
life is over
older than the trees
younger than the mountains
[Music]
take it home
i belong
to west virginia
[Music]
take me home
to the
[Music]
place west virginia
take me home
[Music]
west virginia
country road
take me home
[Music]
country roads